first of all let me just say officially
for the camera how wonderful it is to
see you again in person you too yeah
this is just such a and like i love that
you're going through all these amazing
life things like at the same time right
we're talking off camera just a little
bit about like oh how's fam whatever but
you're like out on your own now and
you're on this massive massive tour
like what is
what is um occupying your mind the most
right now
i mean there's so much changing right
now i'm just trying to stay alive
i'm honestly just trying to like my life
model right now is taking hour by hour
because you think too far ahead yeah
it's too much so it is chaos yeah it is
chaos it is chaos for sure yeah it's
very busy i'm trying very hard to be
brutally honest which is like a very
lovely like it's something that i think
to myself sometimes too when i'm like
okay here we go how often do you find
yourself
in that position where you're like
i need to tell you uh the truth about
this thing but i don't want to really
hurt your feelings yeah yeah um
i mean
i don't know i feel like
i feel like i am a very brutally honest
person i'm very much like what you see
is what you get yeah i'll be i'll be
very straight up until the day i die for
sure for sure yeah and i just
immediately put myself in a position now
where she is like okay i'm going to be
don't ask me anything about yourself
carlos because i'm going to be honest
okay well let's talk about um i mean the
up coming up my i usually think i can
fly yeah i think it's very interesting
because we're kind of like watching you
take off right now thank you
it's
where did the
the title come from why is it i used to
think i could fly so
i've actually had this idea of titling
an album
in this direction because i i feel like
ever since i was younger i always just
like would always have dreams that i
could you know fly uh and i was obsessed
with this whole concept and when i was
younger i feel like everyone's like very
fearless and has no insecurities haven't
really been you know faced with reality
yet and then i i feel like so much
happened where i graduated high school
turned 18 moved to la and so much was
changing at the same time and you know i
kind of got a taste of like what real
life feels like for the first time okay
um and so the concept kind is built
based on like going through
so many different things um this past
summer
do you think that you've found your
sound yet
no no no still working i think that my
album literally has like 10 million
genres into one
um but i honestly think sometimes it's a
good thing it's like that's the sound is
like trying to experiment as much as
possible because there's so much music
out there right now like it's honestly
trying to just like push yourself as an
artist so for you is it the process of
like okay i like
this sound and let's try and go in this
direction or you're trying to like
reach out in all directions so that you
experience it all and go uh maybe one
day i'll land on something that's
specific like what like what's that
process like for you i mean maybe one
one day i'll make an album that's like
fully one style and one genre but i
think for right now is like my debut
album yeah it's like i want people to
know like what i can do yeah um and i
think it's like crazy that i still
haven't released my album yet yeah um
so i i just wanna i wanna reach
everyone's liking i want to make sure
that every single person has like a
taste of what they they would like to
listen to can i be brutally asked what
tell me
i get i get a real like anticipation
vibe off of you really yeah like you're
you're at the spot now where you're
again you're on this tour right
and previous to this we were all like
no one can see
us we're all by ourselves at home yeah
and then the idea of getting out there
must have been very exciting but then
also the anticipation of people finally
being able to get this like yeah
what's the space like between finishing
the album
and then
the idea that people are finally going
to be able to have the whole thing in
their hands
it actually came together pretty quick
um i started writing it in like june
um and i didn't actually write any good
songs until like august
uh but i i feel like i feel like because
since the start of the pandemic when i
was literally 16 years old
there's been so much time that's passed
by yeah that
like two years of your life from 16 to
18 is like a big jump yeah and i feel
like i've just been like patiently
waiting and like you know i was writing
but not really writing and then this
summer was the first time where i could
actually sit down and be like okay i'm
starting this piece of work
and now it's like actually here which is
frightening i want to go back to i
didn't write any good songs until august
like i didn't
i it was really interesting because as
soon as i
as soon as i got to la i was put in all
these big fancy like writing sessions
there were so many people in the room i
literally was like i can't write with
you looking at me like
i'm usually right like alone so
it was finding out like who i worked
best with um and it ended up usually
being like one or two people so like my
whole album ended up being just like me
and two other people or one other person
but at the beginning i was in sessions
with like seven people at a time
and they were trying to like manufacture
these songs and i'm like this is not it
and so it took you just being like okay
i can't
have all of this energy yeah we gotta
focus in yeah otherwise then my message
doesn't get across you know i think what
makes you know me and my fans
relationships so good is the fact that i
know what i want to say and then they
also connect to that like they they
connect to my conversations that i need
to bring to the table and if i have you
know someone who's completely unrelated
to me speaking for me it doesn't work
yeah okay so with that in mind i want to
say this you broke me first has been
streamed over a billion times
with that knowledge
you know and i don't know if it was
streamed a billion times
you know when you were putting your
songs together but yeah do you go oh man
i gotta i gotta do something that does
that again
yeah the pressure definitely is there
once you've
experienced a certain level of something
i think and that's just honestly just
like your own expectations that you put
on yourself is i'm like i want to
constantly do better and i want to write
something better i want to write
something new i don't want to do that
again because once a song like that
comes out then a million of those songs
come out yes a whole new genre needs to
be like created yeah which is wild is
part of the whole like exploring
different sounds
a concerted effort to not be boxed into
that first big hit
yeah i'm i i definitely don't want to
create what i created two years ago when
i was 16. yeah i mean i i had totally
different things to say i sang different
i sounded different i was in a different
mental space so it's it's now like
figuring out um you know because my fans
have grown up with me it's like they're
in a different place as well so it's
figuring out where we are like as a
collective so help me out with this idea
because i know that the two things
aren't analogous but they must help each
other out um you're used to being the
center of attention like competitive
dance is a very tough thing to do yeah
right so not not only competing with
other people but also being on stage a
lot of people look at the idea of just
being on stage when they're kid right
like
no right i can't but this is what you
grew up doing right and you just said to
me that being in a writing room with a
bunch of people was tough because you
didn't want them all watching you
so yeah
it's really weird i think sometimes like
i'll i'll be sitting at a dinner table
with like eight people and i won't say
like one word
if i'm one-on-one with someone i can
like talk their ear off but then if i'm
in a room full of like
20 000 people i can like say whatever i
want yeah it's so strange um just like
the difference of like you know
they feel like
they're not judging you when you're on
stage i feel like it's like people are
just enjoying art and so it's so much
easier to be when you're i feel like
sometimes i'm more myself when i am
doing my art yes um than when i'm just
like taped in a in a in a normal setting
i feel like that's harder for me to like
figure out who i am so there is that
like easily at least two people there
does like the tape feels like i'm at a
dinner table and i just wanted to look
at me totally and the one that's out
there going like look at me this is my
thing no it's strange i have like a
full-on alter ego when i go on well they
say you should do that right right i
gotta no it's weird i like
turn into a completely different person
it's very funny amazing and the two
shall not meet or two no i mean they
definitely know each other
so describe to me then the feeling of
what it's been like to actually be out
in front of people again and you know
like you said they've grown with you but
yeah like you you know them from social
media right but to see them sing this
your stuff back to you completely
different oh my gosh i think it's like
the most validating feeling as an artist
to like
hear people sing back your words and i
think for the longest time it was so
strange because i was releasing all this
music and
i all i could see were like numbers on a
screen and numbers you can't like a
human brain can't process the idea of
streams or youtube views it's like so
superficial yeah and it's been when you
actually get in a room where people know
all the words and are like feeling
everything it's
that's like the best feeling in the
world so how does that actually change
your game plan like you have a game plan
before you get out there right you've
got to sing there's choreography there's
all this and then you get out there and
people are singing everything back to
you and maybe they know moves or
whatever yeah so how does that change
the way that you actually
perform i mean that's where my alter ego
comes out
because
um you don't expect you don't expect to
react that way yeah you feel like you're
like a totally different person and and
and sometimes my parents will be like
it's so funny watching me like be like a
disaster backstage and then get on stage
and be you know
feel like i have all my together yeah
this and then backstage and just a
disaster again yes 100
well your support on this tour by you
know by two other artists who are in
similar
situations what's that been like um i
mean it's incredible i think having
women around me who are so talented and
so young is so inspiring i love it
and like tick tock has been such a huge
part of all of this how much is it a
part of your every day
oh i mean social media is huge right now
um just in any artist's career it's
weird because
i think the energy that you have to put
into social media is like a whole nother
job like it's it's crazy because i'm
like i'm a musician i want to be writing
music i'm supposed to be focusing on
touring and doing all these things like
people used to do they used to just tour
and write and that was their job and now
it's like you have to
you know have this whole other life on
top of that with like six different
platforms and it's like the craziest
the craziest job and people are like you
gotta post ten times a day right you
guys
like where what what am i doing
i'm busy right now which one of which
one of me is doing that's right right
um so
i'm curious about what you're like if
you sit and you're actually scrolling
and you catch the whole like someone
took your song and then flipped it and
did their own version of it yeah what's
that feeling like for you
um it's so interesting to watch it's so
interesting to watch these people how
they interpret like my music because
sometimes they'll like flip my songs and
it'll be like a totally different
message than how i originally intended
it to be yeah which is
just crazy i think that's why music is
so like subjective because everyone
processes it differently how close do
you feel right now
to like the version of you that was a
fan that would be doing stuff like that
oh
i mean
i don't i don't know i feel like i'm
still that person you know what i mean
like i feel like
so much has happened but like also i
haven't changed like at all yeah like i
feel like i feel like the exact same
person yeah um
and i think that's
just because i
i i feel very grounded to my roots still
i don't think i'll ever
you know i don't think i'll ever really
lose my head in the clouds because i
feel like i i you know coming from like
calgary and coming from
like just like my roots i don't i don't
think that i could ever like completely
change into a whole other person that's
amazing to hear
it's just cool because like when you
walk in you looked like a million bucks
right like you look like a superstar
thank you and you're like hey
let's go see you again hey right right
um so speaking of that you
you're in a position though now where
you get to meet people that you were a
fan of yeah it might have been like oh
my gosh
you did work with the huffs on step into
the movies which must have been wild
yeah so fun and to and to use your whole
skill set and something really fun tell
me about that experience um it was a
great opportunity it was really crazy
because i had to learn it one day and
then we were in the middle of like
filming a million videos rehearsing for
tour like i filmed that little segment
of the oscars like pre-show thing yeah
um and i was like wearing heels for the
first time like it was whatever it was
like
[ __ ] show and then like i went
immediately to like rehearsals that day
and then filmed a video like later that
night so it was like all very quick but
honestly it was like such an honor i
think because honestly as a dancer um i
know so much about like old iconic dance
movies
and you know all the legends and so many
people my age have no idea who they are
so it was very cool to like bring light
to some of these like crazy movies it's
a little bit frustrating when when you
try to reference something like singing
in the rain or whatever and people are
like yeah no like my my last music video
was fully referenced by chorus line and
i'm like oh people are going to get this
immediately and like only like a few
select individuals got it which was wild
before we wrap i want to talk about um
without coming to it with sean
like
like high
right like that's got to be something
really exciting yeah i mean honestly i
have
i have no idea how i got into this like
position um
but he's like genuinely like the
sweetest person i've ever met which i
feel so lucky because i'm like i've only
met people in the industry that i really
respect cool um
so
and that's like everything i i would
like is like meet idols who are just as
incredible in real life and even better
and he's been like now such like a
mentor to me and just like a friend and
has been uh really amazing so i'm really
excited to go tour it'll be it'll be
crazy it'll be awesome have you had any
time in your apartment yet
a little bit yeah
the first part of the summer i had time
in my apartment and i
tried to do adulting things
did not work out
well listen it looks like you're doing
things pretty well right now congrats on
everything so far thank you thank you
you